a
[Música]
d
cuántas veces nos atormenta en el camino
la desconsoladora sensación de aspirar a
lo imposible esto es algo que me planteo
prácticamente todos los días en algún
momento ya sea cuando estoy trabajando
en la oficina cuando estoy entrenando me
voy a dormir
y este soy yo en el año 2000 ese día me
había graduado de licenciado en comercio
internacional
este año un domingo de invierno estaba
viendo televisión
un programa típico de domingo y conocer
la historia de marcos arretche marcos es
un atleta de la zona de mar del plata
que había clasificado al campeonato
mundial de distancia ironman
el triatlón es un deporte que consta de
tres disciplinas
nadar pedalear y correr y el ironman es
un triatlón en el que se nadan 3800
metros se pedalea 180 km y se corre una
maratón para terminar 42 kilómetros 195
metros
a los que estaban conmigo
y les digo si algún día voy a correr un
ironman
y esas imágenes
habían
movilizado un montón de cosas dentro mío
recordándome mi infancia cuando hacía
natación
y jugábamos al triatlón
y eso me hizo
expresar ese deseo
al tiempo inconscientemente al terminar
la jornada de trabajo salí a correr como
para terminar el día ni pensaba que
podía llegar a volver a hacer deporte a
nivel competitivo
pero
cuando un deseo
evoluciona se hace recurrente se
transforma en un sueño
dijo que los sueños son la evolución del
deseo
porque los sueños por cumplir son el
motor de nuestra vida
son los que nos llevan a ir tomando
diferentes caminos para cumplirlo y así
nuestra vida va tomando diferentes
rumbos
bueno con el tiempo esas salidas a
correr después de terminar el día de
trabajo se empezará a intensificar y
podía decir que ya estaba entrenando y
comenzaba a participar en algunas
carreras de calle 38 kilómetros 10
kilómetros una media maratón 21
kilómetros como algo inalcanzable
y así fue que fue integrando a mis
entrenamientos
la natación era mi deporte de chico y el
ciclismo y sin darme cuenta
me estaba encaminando y había vuelto
hacer triatlón
el grupo de amigos estaba cada vez más
nutrido de gente que también corría
y de esa manera sin tomar mucha
conciencia estaba encaminado en aquel
deseo
dije era un sueño y era el participar de
un ironman alguna vez
y fue a fines del 2004 que ese sueño
se transformó en objetivo
en mayo del 2005 iba a correr en brasil
en florianópolis un ironman
y cuándo
nos ponemos el objetivo de cumplir un
sueño
tengo que estar muy seguro que es lo que
queremos porque
si bien vamos a disfrutar ese camino
hacia el objetivo ver momentos
en lo que
nos vamos a replantear si realmente vale
la pena el esfuerzo que estamos haciendo
para cumplirlos y ese objetivo
es realmente lo que queremos y así fue
como en la preparación del ironman de
florianópolis 2005 conocí cantidad de
nuevas sensaciones ya este segmento no
sabía lo que era entrenar más de una
hora hora y media y ya estaba entrenando
entre 5 y 6 horas
me pasaba cuatro horas ferrer a la
bicicleta bajaba y salía a correr una
obra más
y empecé a conocer lo que era hasta
enfermarse
por el esfuerzo
yo voy a sufrir los entrenamientos si
bien disfrutaba también lo sufría y
llegué a decir dos semanas más si se
termina esto corre y ya está
pero bueno
llegó la madrugada del 26 de mayo del
2005 y estaba en la playa de schürrer él
todavía era de noche sentía la arena
fría en los pies miraba alrededor y no
entendía nada
pero salió el sol y con el disparo de
largada todo fluyó
después de 11 horas y 53 minutos de
carrera estaba cruzando el arco
cumpliendo un sueño de esa experiencia
que era única sabía que no iba a ser la
única que esto era lo que quería para mí
no claro
yo tenía todo un desafío ahora que
congeniar a las horas dedicadas al
deporte con el trabajo
y así fue como a partir de ese año 2005
bonito de los años a florianópolis a
correr
el ironman incluso en el 2007 cuando me
casó viajamos a eeuu
a correr otro ironman de luna de miel
ahora aquí en sueño inalcanzable un
deseo que empezó como algo
efímero yo era parte de mi vida estaba
naturalizado con los años también iba
mejorando mi performance en las carreras
yo empezaba
a nacer un nuevo sueño y era el de
clasificar aquel campeonato mundial que
se hace en hawai
al que sólo llegaban los mejores atletas
del mundo de cada categoría
entonces le planteó a mi entrenador
este sueño que estaba naciendo y le digo
que tengo que hacer yo para aspirar a
meter un tiempo que me posicione entre
los mejores de mi categoría y me permita
aspirar a esa plaza del ironman de hawai
llegar respuesta fué
durísima tajante el conejo vieja te
pues para clasificar al ironman de hawai
tenés que volver a nacer
me mató
y esas palabras quedaron sonando en mi
cabeza varios días
para mí clasificar al ironman de hawai
era algo imposible pero era lo que yo
quería
y si yo lo quería cumplir sabía que
tenía que hacer varios cambios
el primero fue cambiar de entrenador
lógico
y empecé a entrenar con un amigo que
también era profe que si bien no tenía
la experiencia del otro si me conocía
muy bien y sabía lo que significaba para
mí
conseguir ese sueño
y entre los dos nos propusimos ese
objetivo clasificar al ironman de hawai
así volvía a florecer pues el año
2011-2012 si bien los tiempos bajaban no
alcanzaban todavía para meterme entre
los mejores de mi categoría
y al volver de esa carrera del 2012 fue
que me replanteé
hice una autocrítica y me di cuenta que
si bien ha hecho había hecho varios
cambios no eran los cambios que se
necesitaban no eran lo suficientemente
radicales los cambios para aspirar a
estar entre los mejores y ahí fue que
nos juntamos con mi entrenador por su
lado hizo los cambios y los ajustes que
se necesitaban en la planificación y por
otro lado
yo realmente hice cambios que se
necesitaban cambie mi hábito alimenticio
hábito de sueño del lugar de
entrenamiento para optimizar esa
planificación que me hacía pero sobre
todo cambia la cabeza no concebía la más
mínima posibilidad
de dejar pasar una sesión de
entrenamiento incluso dentro de la
sesión entrenamiento no podía regalar un
minuto pero claro tenía tratamientos de
cuatro horas y había que congeniar los
con el trabajo y la familia
así fue como una vez una mañana 9 de la
mañana tenía que estar en el acto del
colegio de mi hija después a la oficina
y no tenía más formas de entrenar ese
día así que para cumplir los cuatro de
la mañana sonó el despertador 445 estaba
arriba de la bicicleta pedaleando por la
costanera del rosario y nueve y media
estaba en el acto también paso con días
de trabajo el despertador sonaba a las 5
de la mañana a las 6 estaba entrenando
nueve y media día ya estaba en la
oficina
así llegué
[Música]
la madrugada del 30 de mayo del 2013 que
estaba una vez más tras la línea de
largada en florianópolis pero esta vez
el objetivo era grande
tenía que meterme entre los mejores para
conseguir un objetivo y clasificar
durante la carrera cantidad de momentos
me vinieron a la cabeza charlas que
habíamos tenido con amigos en diferentes
reuniones que tengas charlas decíamos
busque que fulanito y porque tiene
genética
tiene muchas condiciones al otro este es
un talentoso
yo
sabía que había hecho un gran esfuerzo y
siempre cuando escuchaba esa frase decía
sí
pero no nos olvidemos que el esfuerzo
supera el talento cuando el talento no
se está esforzando y yo había hecho todo
lo que tenía me alcance para lograrlo
cuando cruzó el arco de llegada el reloj
e decía nueve horas treinta no sabía
cómo había llegado y me encuentro con mi
papá que estaba del otro lado nos había
acompañado porque mi hermano también
hacia el debut en la distancia y
desaforado desencajado dice que a este
cuarto que a este cuarto eso
[Música]
me clasificaba directamente al ironman
de hawai
y fue en ese momento que me di cuenta
que era cierto aquel 2010 había vuelto a
nacer
y ahora tenía cuatro meses por delante
para buscar mi mejor versión y disfrutar
lo que tanto había soñado y tanto había
visto de chico por televisión en vídeos
que era correr entre los mejores del
mundo
en la isla de hawai
y así sigue
a octubre del 2013 en la que esta vez
estaba flotando en la línea de largada y
a mi alrededor y veía a los mejores
atletas del mundo de cada categoría en
la distancia ironman y decía los tipos
nadan fuertes
si no grado fuerte me pasan por arriba y
los escuchaba hablar entre ellos y en el
idioma que entendía la cuenta que se
estaban agrupando por el tiempo que
quería meter parezca es más rápido
estos tipos son lo mejor el mundo y el
noventa uno tiene que
autoconvencerse que si está ahí y darse
cuenta de si está ahí es porque también
se lo ganó y ese día
sonó el disparo fluyo como el 2005 y
disfrute de haber corrido en el paraíso
y cuando cruce el arco de llegada con
las manos azules de tocar el cielo me di
cuenta que una vez más esto era lo que
quería para mí yo quería volver pero si
quería volver tenía que buscar la
clasificación nuevamente cada año volver
a clasificar
era más difícil porque el nivel amateur
cada vez será más competitivo y así como
mis objetivos deportivos iban creciendo
también lo hacían los familiares y los
profesionales
ya tenía mi propia oficina
y estaba en camino a mi tercer hijo
tenía que hacer tetris y malabares para
congeniar el entrenamiento
con mi vida personal profesional y
familiar
pero pude volver los años siguientes a
correr el ironman de hawai clasifique y
fui año 2014 15-16 en el 2015
los equipos primera vez entre los
mejores días de mi categoría
todos estos años cuando termine al día
siguiente de la carrera del iacene de
premiación y
y me acercaba al escenario y veía el
podio y veía a los cinco mejores del
mundo que subían
y los alminares de estos tipos y ahí
están los cinco mejores del mundo estos
son los mejores del mundo
yo puedo empecé a soñar
con llegar a ese en ese podio
y así era que volvía dejado allí a los
dos meses buscaba la clasificación para
poder estar
asegurado y poder volver y prepararme
con la mayor anticipación y en las
carreras clasificatorias ya era
algo natural ponerme como objetivo la
clasificación y también el podio
llegaron los podios en los
clasificatorios pero corría en hawai y
no llegaba y no todavía no alcanzaba así
llegué al año 2018
en el que también en el proceso cantidad
de veces aparecía el fantasma de esto
tiene sentido vale la pena
entonces son mucho mejor que yo entrenan
mejor tienen más condiciones tienen más
talento tienen más genética y ustedes
vieron que a mí la genética no era una
hamburguesa así que cada vez me tenía
que esforzar más
y así estuve
octubre del 2018 flotando una vez más
como gracia seis veces había estado en
la largada del ironman de hawai del
campeonato mundial a donde sólo llegaban
los mejores del mundo pero con un
objetivo muy ambicioso
que era subir a ese podio
tenía que hacer mi carrera perfecta
en ese momento me acordé cuando era
chico con mis hermanos nos gustaba jugar
hacer edificios con cartas de seda lo
único que sabíamos era que si queríamos
hacer un edificio perfecto tengo que
empezar por poner cada carga perfecta y
con esa imagen larga ese día si quería
hacer mi carrera perfecta no podía
pensar en el resultado final tenía que
empezar por dar cada brazada perfecta en
la natación cada pedaleada tenía que ser
perfecta y en la maratón cada paso lo
tenía que dar de la mejor manera que se
puede dar un paso
y traté de mantenerme concentrado y
abstraído del entorno no me importaba
cómo iban los demás corredores yo tenía
que hacer mi carrera perfecta y cuando
faltaban 500 metros para cruzar el arco
un amigo que estaba afuera me grita que
al que había pasado
era de mi categoría
que había quedado cuarto
y al día siguiente me estaba subiendo al
podio entre los cinco mejores del mundo
[Aplausos]
por eso cuántas veces nos atormenta en
el camino la desconsoladora sensación de
aspirar a lo imposible pero si nosotros
trabajamos nuestros sueños y nuestros
objetivos
con pasión con confianza
con compromiso humildad y respeto pero
sobre todo con paciencia y constancia
que al día que lo imposible se hace
posible
más aún porque no natural
[Aplausos]
[Música]
no no